une forme inspirée de la nature est une
structure en forme de grains de café
voilà à quoi ressemble premier bâtiment
imprimé en 3d en europe
une prouesse technique et d'innovation
imaginé par la start up extrait le
pavillon de 18 mètres carrés a été
imprimé en moins de 24 heures plus tôt
que de couler du béton dans des moules
comme on le fait habituellement on vient
imprimée du béton des couches une couche
au dessus de l'autre exactement ce qu'on
voit ici vous voyez sur le côté avec
l'aspect un petit peu des couches il ya
une partie qui est enduite voilà pour
des questions d'aspect et on a laissé à
nu une partie avec avec les couches
si la fabrication 3d est déjà utilisée
depuis plusieurs années dans l'industrie
son exploitation à grande échelle reste
marginal c'est justement l'objet de
cette première exposer les avantages et
les avancées induit par l'impression 3d
dans le futur l'objectif c'est d'emmener
le robot là où on doit construire
il va construire probablement avec des
matériaux locaux puis ensuite on
enlèvera le robot et ça peut du coup
permettre de créer des constructions
très rapidement dans des endroits où il
ya de la migration de personnes ou dans
des endroits comme l'afrique ou les
matériaux sont pas tout à fait les mêmes
que ce qu'on peut trouver ici
donc ça change complètement la façon de
penser urbanisme en attendant
l'investissement important d'un acteur
du btp aucun projet concret ne prévoit
la création d'un bâtiment 3d à usage
réel